beneath the Waters of the Atlantic Ocean
within sheltered estuaries
a crustacean invasion is transforming
the New England coast they're horribly
invasive and you know you find them on
just about every continent as warming
Waters Drive Maine's iconic lobsters
northward invasive European green crabs
are filling the Gap surging in number
and devouring the Region's muscles
scallops and clams
they eat tons and tons of the shellfish
here in Maine we have soft shell clams
which was historically speaking I think
Maine's second largest fishery and The
Landings there have really really
plummeted as these guys have become more
pervasive
to get to their prey the teeming mass of
green dig and sniff through a
life-sustaining ecosystem Mike Macy and
a handful of entrepreneurial new
englanders say at least part of this
illusion amounts to Poetic Justice
eating the Invaders
and just a few centimeters across green
crabs are too small to pick for meat so
restaurants such as the Black Trumpet
buy the molting ones and serve them up
whole as fried soft shell crabs you
crunch them like like basically popcorn
and you can season them with with
anything you want and I it blew my mind
at the Tamworth distillery in rural New
Hampshire Will Robinson is pouring Crab
Trap or whiskey at 65 dollars a bottle
really the ick factor is there and
that's part of why the story has taken
off obviously your your crab and spirit
it just makes makes most people want to
kind of throw up in their mouth a little
bit but if I can get them to taste it it
completely changes their mind at the
dawn of the 19th century there were no
green crabs here they arrived on these
Shores and the cargo holds of European
trading vessels for 200 years New
England's brutal Winters have kept their
numbers steady but now with global
warming water temperatures have risen
and grown more hospitable and their
numbers have grown out of control oh
here's one
see now even Fisheries Specialists
struggled to quantify them there's about
as many
grabs that you can imagine as a
possible just to give you an idea of the
numbers we have you take one female she
can produce 180 000 eggs in one clutch
and sometimes they have two clutches a
year
if you believe New England can eat its
way out of its green crab problem but
these culinary Pioneers are working to
turn the tables on the ravenous Invaders
John hendren Al Jazeera Portsmouth New
Hampshire